so what I did in my book the value of
everything was to kind of bring it down
to first principles and ask could it be
that also we've just kind of lost our
way and stopped really debating
something that actually in the course of
the last kind of two hundred years of
thinking about the economy was really
central this question of you know what
is value what is value creation what is
value extraction and what happens when
we either by my mistake or on purpose
end up rewarding value extraction more
than value creation do we get something
called value destruction but you know I
just keep using that word value there
but what is value and notice by the way
that the subtitle is not makers vs.
takers because that's really static that
would lead to the rest of my forty
minutes here kind of making a list of
big bad finance hedge funds credit
default swaps bad and then kind of
saying that something else is good
that's not what I'm going to do is
making and taking the reason I chose
that kind of verb is that we can change
things we can and I hope perhaps we can
talk about it also in the Q&A we can
fundamentally reform how finance is
operating and how certain business
practices have kind of gone astray and
how government has just become a bit too
lame but what's really interesting is
that this kind of concept of making and
taking kind of often comes back after
every financial crisis so I pulled out
this quote here which is very nice one
by big bill Haywood the first industrial
trade unionist in the US writing at the
time of the great crash in 1929 and it's
really interesting because you just
replace the word gold barons by
financial sector and it kind of rings
what a lot of people and communities
around the world were saying so the
barbarous gold barons they didn't find
the gold they didn't mind the gold they
didn't mill the gold but by some weird
magic alchemy all the gold belongs to
them and so this is the kind of making
and taking and you know this is kind of
the accusation but so what does this
mean what does it mean to actually think
about the economy in terms of certain
areas being kind of productive certain
being unproductive and really thinking
about how to make sure we're steering
activities
inside what I call in the book the
production boundary and unfortunately
what happens when we no longer talk
about value and just kind of assume you
know Silicon Valley's full of wealth
creators we end up allowing stories
literally just stories and narratives
and discourses about value and wealth
creation to take over and what I'm going
to basically argue is that when that
happens we allow value extraction to be
disguised as value creation and you know
it's not that the landlords and the
1700's and I'll get to them in a minute
weren't extracting value but they didn't
pretend to be innovative didn't pretend
to be value creators they just say give
me your damn money and people gave them
the money Adam Smith called landlords
fees
there was no masquerading and again I'm
not gonna don't worry I'm sure there's
many tech people here in the room I'm
not gonna start making accusations of
again whether it's tech or finance or
government officials as value extractors
but this kind of masquerading exercise
is a problem and you know there's I was
really struck how one year just one year
after the crisis the head of Goldman
Sachs Lloyd blank Fein said with a
completely straight face it was not an
after-dinner speech where he's trying to
make people laugh yeah completely
serious look it up just google it and
the FT put this quote that Goldman Sachs
workers were the most productive in the
world you know I mean this is a period
where they had just been bailed out ten
billion dollars by the US government
because of what happened with the
financial crisis there was plenty of
evidence that it was in fact to a large
extent not only the activities of the
large investment banks that at least
partially led to the financial crisis
and yet this bold statement of we are
the most productive in the world and so
this whole concept of how do we measure
productivity do teachers say we are the
most productive in the world and if not
could it be that how we are actually
accounting for a value in the system
creates actually a self-fulfilling
prophecy that it allows some actors and
the economy to be there
bold and arrogant and and and to be able
to claim even just logically in terms of
how we do the counting that they are so
productive but then again I I mentioned
story so this idea that again wealth
creators in Silicon Valley or in the
case of brexit when brexit I'm still
hoping it doesn't happen but um happened
you know this idea that we have to at
least protect those really valuable
sectors which which were producing value
for the UK economy so financial services
and I'll mention also later the way that
the word value is used in sectors like
the pharmaceutical industry to justify
very high increases and prices so
recently a price of an antibiotic went
up by four hundred percent overnight and
the idea that value-based pricing could
somehow be used to justify that as quite
extraordinary and on the opposite
spectrum I've read II mentioned teachers
you don't hear teachers calling
themselves we are so productive but also
the state itself how we talk about the
state we don't talk about it really as
creating value at best we talk about it
as redistributing value or enabling or
de-risking the value creators so these
are really just words and narratives and
discourses which are kind of just I
don't say but just kind of
stories right economics is not nuclear
physics and we've allowed by not
actually talking about value these
stories to be out there and almost not
even questioned